we're told that joe started his math
homework he finished 23 problems by
himself
he finished 13 more problems with help
from sal i don't know if they're talking
about me or not
and then they say there are nine math
problems left
and then they ask us how many math
problems did joe have
when he started so pause this video and
see if you can work through that before
we do it together
all right so the way my brain thinks
about it is there's some amount that he
started with
so
let's put a big bar over here this is
some amount
that joe started with so let me write
that starting
amount
and then he was able to do many of them
so he's finished 23 problems by himself
so let me draw 23 here
so he was able to finish 23
by himself
then he finished 13 more with help from
someone with my name maybe it's me
so then he did 13 more with help from
sal so that's 13 right over there
and then the total amount left was 9.
so the total amount left has to be able
to finish up be just as long as our
starting amount so this is 9 right over
here so this is left
thus 23 was the ones he did by himself
the 13 was with help from me and then he
had 9 left
so if you want to know the starting
amount how many math problems did joe
have when he started you have to add
together 23 plus 13 plus 9. so how do we
do that well let's do it one at a time
so let's just think about how many he
finished and then we can add to that how
many is left and that's the starting
amount
so the amount that he finished so that's
this amount right over here the ones he
did by himself plus the amount once he
did with sal
that's going to be 23
plus
13. now 23 plus 13 is the same thing if
i just think about it i have two tens
here so that's 20
plus 3
plus 10 plus 3 that one is in the tens
place plus 10
plus three well that's the same thing as
if i just look at the
if i look just look at the tens right
over there
twenty plus ten
plus three
plus three
20 plus 10 is 30 so this is going to be
equal to 30
plus 3 plus 3 is 6 so this is going to
be equal to 36. so this whole amount
right over here the amount of problems
that joe either did by himself or with
the help of sal
that is 36 problems and so to figure out
the starting amount we just have to
figure out the total that he did
plus how many are left to get the
starting amount so what is 36 plus 9
well the way my brain thinks about it
let me just do it right over here 36
plus 9 is equal to what
well this is the same thing as 30 plus 6
plus 9
and 6 plus 9 you may already know is 15.
another way you could think about it is
if you start at 9 you have to add 1 to
get to 10 and then you have 5 left over
from the 6 to get to 15. so another way
to rewrite this 30 plus 15 is the same
thing
as 30
plus
10
plus
5
30 plus 10
this right over here that's 40 so it's
going to be 40 plus 5 which is equal to
45.
so joe had 45 problems when he started
he did 23 by himself then he did 13 and
he would have 9 left and you would see
if you started with 45 and if you were
to subtract 23 and then subtract 13 you
actually would indeed have 9 left